welcome to this video playing a feed
master of all Vereen what should i do
well maybe this is Lillian get some
variety into the game night off there
should be two hmm yeah I go for the
original night off with e5 I always feel
that this is a bit easier to play in
comparison to UM to the to the e6 type
of setup the ravening and slave-owning
type of setup a for early hmm do you
play no I think we should be 6a 596 is
probably not a big problem okay now is
going going with this yeah I'm not an
expert recently I had a game with Queen
c7 and Bishop c4 this would oh it's cool
type of night off yeah maybe maybe just
just accept that for once 97 yeah I
guess playing this very quickly probably
all this is is known hmm yeah
do you play b5 here takes no chicks
possible oh the Essex bond I just
realized that this might be just hanging
now but if I take with the Queen it also
looks a bit strange okay let's do that
John he is just taking it yeah pretty
very greedy feeling no of course it's
just good to take it i blundered the
blonde at the pawn basically I let's say
I accepted to the loss of the prom
because the other line also looked a bit
weird um yeah what's now how to get some
camera to play maybe night see for now
taking on on f2a on b2 of course not on
f2 ok at least I have two bishops ray
watch now he might take play Bishop g5
95 this type of this type of thing ok
maybe I can put some pressure on on the
queenside this is always a bit
uncomfortable for why the night on b3 is
really misplaced quite often it is it
idea simply to play 92 ended over to the
Kings side now they came this position
it's um certainly better for white due
to the pawn but it's um yeah I can take
him I take on f4 takes e4 Queen takes
Bishop takes on the front but be too
hangs yeah okay let's say I grab that it
I don't know he's allowing that but that
is surprising really is the drawback to
that I don't I don't see it at the
moment
isn't isn't this quite okay now I mean
White's position feels a bit loose see
three years now I'm not grounded anymore
the snide and I have active pieces maybe
you can take on d6 I'm just wondering
about that huh Queen to see form
yeah I can take play rugby 3 and there
should be ok but there's something
better Queen deform could before but
it's not really threatening much ok I
mean this is certainly not bad um night
f2 is this may be a possibility when I
it's got 95 rabbits still maybe
oh I don't know 118 I didn't really pay
much attention to the clock only only
see that now okay so i give the check
yeah if you will have neither he will
have g5 for the night okay maybe I'm
activate the bishop get it here
yeah a giant morning oops okay yeah it's
a fairly active position night can go to
F for the only thing is I shouldn't get
made the chair maybe do this first so
that I can I can escape to to h6 look
everyone or can play 95 or look you on
ok
yeah that's it's very very equal
disposition only thing not yeah
Equalists the time thirties 2032 30
seconds it's not not that great okay
yeah I went into a self pin check no
rock d 2 of course and nothing's going
on really great yeah okay I had the
Tizen the time wasn't i simply forgot to
pop the clock in the middle of the game
now can there's there's simply not
nothing going on yet I can just return
Dwight has no way to improve I can
always play rook to you one night be too
and unpin it just it's just nothing
going on but they're ok I will probably
lose it on time anyway because I just
fell asleep somehow here and yeah here I
really wonder if I had some some
improvement what does the computer doing
here so now I've got that girl went here
I mean this is probably okay enough for
four check for new proposition yeah
there was some some points before where
why I could have played played better
here bouquet one is very good for white
yeah I thought I go f6 but um hmm days
he has this smooth then possibly deform
yeah that's not not very comfortable
yum yum yum it's um I was just terribly
slow this game I mean not that I'm quick
otherwise but it's um it's really far
too slow the computer even gives black a
substantial advantage here which is
believable I mean I've got the better
look at these got the real structure but
no way that I'm ever going to do
something with this term with two
minutes less on the clock just a very
very slow game and in the opening i
don't i don't really know this is
certainly an online and here maybe
something else if I the serve certainly
not enough compensation maybe I should
play em I don't know some some rock
moves that is something generally useful
and then it get continues alright thanks
for watching